live local now good morning 5 30 is the  time I was telling John earlier this  morning I left the house and um the dog  Napoleon he was in three blankets and  the only reason I knew he was there is  because I saw an ear he was all cuddled  up right I feel that it was chilly so  here's are you guys are you two blanket  people or one blanket people oh what do  you reckon well I'm a I'm like two and  then Mitchell is like none oh my God  Sherry we're creeping into maybe two  blanket territory I feel like for some  folks well yeah that or footy pajama  weather yes flipper songs the fuzz I  like my feet were so cold last night oh  that's that's how you get sick and you  can't sleep good when your feet are cold